y la inflación se ha convertido en una
de las principales preocupaciones para
la economía mundial sobre todo en medio
de una recuperación económica tras dos
años del inicio de la pandemia de kobe
19 en estos últimos meses hemos
experimentado subidas de los precios que
alcanzan máximos históricos en europa y
eeuu y que sin duda han tenido
repercusión en nuestra región de américa
latina y el caribe pero qué está pasando
con la inflación mundial podríamos estar
a puertas de una recesión es la
inflación más dañina que la recesión
económica pues le preguntamos a nuestro
segundo invitado del día l josé luis de
la cruz el director general del
instituto para el desarrollo industrial
y del crecimiento económico josé luís
gracias por estar con nosotros esta
mañana de jueves en directo américa de
france 24 también nos acompaña en esta
mesa de trabajo nuestro cronista de
economía luís en méndez bridge muchas
gracias a raúl y por supuesto que es un
tema interesante saber cómo está
impactando esta situación que se
presenta a nivel mundial y por ello
vamos a iniciar y
consultándole a nuestro especialista
josé luis de la cruz porque estamos
viviendo este momento de inflación en
gran parte del mundo
bueno yo creo que uno de los factores
que está pesando fuertemente fue el
incremento en el precio de las materias
primas que comenzó a observarse desde
mayo del 2020 es decir recién pasando
los primeros momentos del confinamiento
global y que con la reactivación
económica que se dio primero en china en
el este de asia y que después llegó a
eeuu y el resto del mundo pues lo que
vimos es que esta tendencia se siguió
incrementando que es lo que estamos
observando por ejemplo entre mayo de ese
momento y junio de este año un aumento
de más de 300% en los precios de los
llamados commodities de las materias
primas energía metales y algunos
alimentos a eso hay que agregarle
evidentemente el impacto de la guerra en
ucrania que cortó el suministro de
algunas materias primas de alimentos y
también el confinamiento que por kobe
19s tuvo en algunas regiones de china y
que distó con nuevamente el
funcionamiento de las cadenas de valor
asociadas a las manufacturas china
produce el 24 por ciento del valor
agregado de las manufacturas a nivel
mundial todos estos elementos lo que
plantean es que hay
temas comunes que son los que están
generando ese aumento en la presión en
todo el mundo y que evidentemente
nuestros instantes varios países están
enfrentando serias dificultades para
contener ese incremento de empresas
claro josé luís le preguntó entonces
cómo estarían afrontando los países
latinoamericanos esta situación de la
alta inflación más allá digamos de subir
las tasas de interés en los bancos
centrales y qué medidas también pueden
tomar para contrarrestar las digamos sin
entrar en una recesión para evitar
entrar en una posible recesión económica
porque esa es justamente la pregunta que
en estos momentos se hace a américa la
tiene en general y la mayor parte del
mundo en realidad porque en el contexto
de américa latina particularmente en
américa del sur el incremento de
empresas de materias primas tiene
claroscuros por un lado le generó en
ingresos excedentes muy importantes a
todas aquellas naciones que además son
proveedoras de alimentos minerales para
el resto del mundo metales él sin
embargo en estos instantes en donde
algunos de esos precios han disminuido
pero la inflación es va en ascenso lo
que está generando es justamente esta
presión en el costo de vida diaria de
las familias y también de las empresas
como enfrentarlo en una medida sin lugar
a dudas es la de política monetaria el
incremento en tasas de interés de la
cual no se pueden desligar porque es
básicamente lo que está haciendo de eeuu
y la unión europea no así china china y
hoy turquía y anuncian reducciones en
tasas de interés cual es el elemento que
ellos tienen y que américa latina
tendría que trabajar para enfrentar
estas medidas esta medida de inflación
en función de alternativa se llama
productividad es decir la industria
pueden tener la capacidad transformadora
de generar valor agregado para reducir
costos que están ahorita llegando por el
lado de materias primas desde la segunda
medida sería incrementar los factores de
productividad al interior sobre todo del
sector industrial y el 13 el aspecto de
evidentemente sí me parece que es
generar acuerdos al interior de su
economía para tratar de contener estos
choques que pareciera van disminuyendo
en al menos en algunos rubros ahora
retomemos el tema de esta inflación
global mencionabas en primer lugar un
incremento de materias primas también el
impacto que ha tenido la guerra en
ucrania pero podríamos incluir en toda
esta situación el tema del problema que
se registró en cuanto a la cadena de
suministro sobre todo a finales 2021
principio de 2022 y que también
impactaron en algunos países por el tema
inflacionario
sin lugar a dudas sin lugar a dudas ese
es un aspecto esencial porque al final
del día la apuesta que durante muchos
años se hizo fue tener una cadena global
de proveeduría en manufacturas y la
fabricación final en varias regiones del
mundo el digamos que el núcleo de esta
producción de manufacturas se ubicó en
china y en varios países del este
asiático el confinamiento que se tuvo a
inicios de 2020 con la pandemia pero que
se replicó hacia finales de 2021 e
inicios de este año y que no ha
terminado del todo pues lo que vino fue
a causar una ruptura del funcionamiento
del justo a tiempo en las cadenas de
mano captura y eso al final del día
sigue estando presente junto con el
problema de los chips por ejemplo en
en china entonces en ese sentido sí creo
que este factor de ruptura de cadenas de
valor es también uno de los elementos
que está digamos exacerbando esta
presión inflación al ahora josé luís
seguimos hablando de china y le pregunto
las implicaciones entonces que podrían
tener para las principales economías
mundiales y también de nuestra región de
américa latina de una reducción de las
tasas de interés en la economía china
bueno yo creo que lo que estamos viendo
es que china lleva otro sentido en
cuanto a cómo reactivar su economía en
china no existe la presión inflacionaria
el último aumento de la inflación fue de
2.5 por ciento el incremento empresas al
productor puede apenas 4.5 por ciento
para los meses de julio evidentemente
que eso le permite al banco central de
china en lugar de subir tasa de interés
la disminuyó ligeramente 10 puntos base
que hace un par de 10 entonces en ese
aspecto el mensaje que están viendo
china es de que ellos van a reactivar su
economía a través de más inversión de
más de proyectos de infraestructura
tanto para básicos como digitales y esto
lo que va a implicar es que en ese
sentido va a existir la posibilidad de
que en esa región del este de asia
encausado china existen oportunidades de
crecimiento económico que es lo que me
parece américa latina va a tener que
buscar cómo lograr engancharse a esa
dinámica de crecimiento que de momento
es la única que se percibe de forma
vigorosa en el mundo ahora en este plan
de américa latina' a acercarse a chinas
ya vemos que china está haciendo
importantes inversiones en algunos
países de la región podría hacer este un
factor también para evitar ese impacto
tanto de la inflación o de caídas en
economía dentro de la región
latinoamericana
sin lugar a dudas ede sin lugar a dudas
que habita china y que lleva al menos 15
años siendo uno de los principales
factores de inversión en américa latina
hace un par de días además china anunció
un programa de desarrollo de
infraestructura digital pero que
curiosamente busca crear host de
desarrollo fuera de china en otros
países y hay una américa latina tiene la
posibilidad no sólo de seguir
participando en esta asociación que
tiene más de una década con china como
proveedor de materias primas sino
también para atraer parte de esas
inversiones que forman parte de ese
proyecto de desarrollo que el gobierno
china anunció hace un par de días y que
en esencia lo que puede hacer es llevar
manufactura innovación y transferencia
de tecnología a otras regiones del mundo
y en donde algunos países de américa
latina podrían calificar para ser parte
de receptores de esa inversión ahí no
podemos dejar de mencionar louis el
acuerdo que anunció el día ayer también
eeuu con taiwán de una posible relación
comercial bilateral también en términos
de tecnología y pues otros temas
comerciales en jos el vista también como
esto impactaría digamos las relaciones
de china américa
bueno yo creo que lo que estamos viendo
en taiwán es justamente una parte más
del escenario económico geopolítico
entre eeuu y china y taiwán es
básicamente el principal productor de
semiconductores en donde tienen
tecnología propia innovación propia pero
también fuertes inversiones de eeuu la
unión europa y algunas otras naciones
entonces este acercamiento que hace eeuu
con taiwán es un tema de seguridad
nacional para estados unidos forman
parte de esta y de este impulso que el
presidente bien ha tratado de dar a los
semiconductores con el programa que
anunció hace poco más de una semana y
que en este sentido sabe que necesita
que taiwán siga operando en el corto
plazo para ser proveedor de esos
semiconductores que necesitan toda la
toda la industria global pero que al
mismo tiempo le permita ir transfiriendo
ciertos procesos productivos a eeuu
entonces yo creo que en ese aspecto
américa latina tiene la oportunidad de
vincularse con china de buscar qué tan
que encadenamientos estratégicos puede
hacer con eeuu ante este reacomodo de
manufactura de alta tecnología que se
está viendo en el mundo ahora por otro
lado hablando de eeuu durante la
pandemia vimos programas de los
gubernamentales para estimular la
economía ahora no atraviesa la economía
estadounidense a su mejor momento una
caída de 14 por ciento durante el primer
trimestre luego una de 0,2 por ciento
durante el segundo estamos hablando de
lo que los especialistas refieren una
recesión técnica en este particular pero
esta recesión podría prolongarse o el
plan anunciado días atrás por el
presidente job aiden podría
amortiguar un poco esta situación
digamos que la respectiva básica que
ahorita se tiene desde que eeuu ha
entrado bien mencionas una recesión
técnica que básicamente es una
desaceleración significativa en su
sector de la construcción también en la
manufactura de bienes durables se ha
comenzado a observarse en lo que se
conoce como inversión fija en
residencial y no residencial pues yo
creo que es todo lo que el valor que nos
lleva es que en el mejor de los casos
eeuu va hacia una desaceleración
significativa en donde lo que habrá que
ver es si el programa de eficiente baile
y seguramente otros programas que irán
surgiendo tienen la capacidad de generar
un aterrizaje sabe desde mi punto de
vista lo que veremos es que este año de
eeuu crecerá alrededor de 1.5 por ciento
y que el año que entra va alcanzar a
crecer poco más de 1% pero esto lo que
sí trae es una mala noticia el dinamismo
de eeuu de otros años se va a perder y
evidentemente eso va a afectar a los
países que son exportadores hacia que el
mercado ahora no se olvide también es
digamos cuáles serían los países más
perjudicados con esta alta inflación que
pasa por ejemplo países que tienen una
hiperinflación como argentina que superó
el costo de vida el aumento anual en más
del 70 por ciento también el tema de
venezuela que a pesar de esta
dolarización e informal izada en el país
nos aleja de la inflación además de
estar mañana porque por supuesto es en
dólares no
bueno yo creo que américa latina hay
casos extremos como los que bien
mencionas en donde lo que estamos
observando desde que no se puede
contener la inflación la capacidad
productiva tampoco es la suficiente para
poder tener un escenario de crecimiento
económico nos me parece que si hay
algunos países venezuela-argentina están
muy cerca de una recesión
una combinación además de contracción
económica con alta inflación que lo que
les va a provocar la necesidad de
aplicar programas de choque y programas
de cambio estructural existen en otro en
otro lado del espectro algunos países
que creo que pueden tener crecimiento
económico aunque sea modesto pero con
presión inflacionaria entre ellos podría
estar méxico brasil chile es en donde me
parece que existen un poco más de
posibilidades y herramientas para tratar
de evitar una recesión y esto al final
del día lo vamos a ver va a estar
también vinculado con lo que ocurra con
los principales socios comerciales de
cada uno de estos países en donde
aquellos que tengan una sociedad fuerte
con la unión europea pues evidentemente
van a sentir los efectos van a sentir
los efectos de una posible recesión en
la tierra